le ch est bien le contraire le roi du
maroc
le président de l'assemblée sans nous
maintenons considérables estime qu' il
avait encouragé par ailleurs une
politique allant dans le sens de la
promotion des libertés publiques liberté
de la presse qui verte et d'association
et de réunion multipartisme peuvent
ainsi être vérifié par tous vos
visiteurs dont le roi cette invitation
difool et son attachement à la justice
l'a fait le probable une démocratie est
par définition pluraliste
elle suppose la pluralité des opinions
et des parties pourraient pour les
divers acteurs politiques ont à faire
entendre leur voix qui sont distinctes
et aux besoins alternative
pourvu que sur l'essentiel c'est-à-dire
l'indépendance et l'intégrité nationale
elle se retrouve à l'unisson seulement
si la majorité applaudit venant les
socialistes restent demain certains
d'entre eux avec
du coup les autres refusant les années
crise notre présence ne signifie pas du
tout une approbation
l orientation de notre régime mais en
même temps
ils ont précisément
montrer notre respect pour le peuple
marocain les communistes avaient décidé
de boycotter purement sentiment nourri
brunner était dans les couloirs pour les
ans je ne me vois pas accueillir un roi
qui portent gravement atteinte à la paix
dans son pays à ses trois heures une
bourse note dont le déroulement de la
visite officielle visite officielle dont
le temps fort aura plus musclée le
discours de l'assemblée